hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one finger death
punch I have been actually very eager to
play this again because someone
suggested that I should get back to it
because I now upload in 60 frames per
second so you guys can actually see how
fluid in awesome this game is and if you
haven't seen the first time I played
this holy crap this game is unbelievably
amazing
now just catching up to it so I'm gonna
go back to these two levels that I just
played either you haven't seen yet which
are mob rounds which are amazing cuz
this is whole bunch of people trying to
kill you but in the end they get killed
back bar pizza watch out yeah I just
it's so much fun and it's just played
with two buttons like that's the whole
point of the game you only use the two
mouse buttons that you have to do these
crazy cool things all the time yeah and
I bet there are like masters of escape
of crap
unbelievably good masters of this game
but I'm just an amateur and I shall only
be an abattoir for now yeah
yeah machine you broke my team oh sorry
Chuck sorry I didn't mean it I didn't
mean to do that I I messed up my apology
okay then it's very different when I was
playing by myself I did not mess up this
much because I was not talking I was
just sitting here with a giant smile on
my face like holy crap yeah no use no
anyway umm this game is so much fun like
you will not even believe how much funs
math how much fun this game can be Bam
Bam Bam Bam
holy crap sorry that one I did not know
I did not time oh I miss the ball of it
no not Valdez come here bang bang oh no
one over there bang bang bang bang bang
mess up it's not even that bad because
it's still so much holida call it up
ball it up phone it falling it oh it's
my ball now cuz the other fish together
pin all their fish yeah
yeah no can some bats which powers now
oh so satisfying so satisfying
oh man I was playing another game to
actually reminded me of the student
reminded that oh my god I need to beat
this game no not too cool around oh gosh
nunchucks their best weapon cap haha I
can't remember we're nunchucks even all
that popular before Bruce Lee like made
him really popular bet I actually don't
know oh now for now I just need to kill
people by Bam Bam Bam come on boom boom
Oh Stu it's fun I sometimes play this
games like a stress reliever just cuz
it's so yeah oh yeah go give me my
nunchuck oh oh oh yes
go to the middle thank you coordinated
I'll get a perfect round eventually but
just not now
God it's just it's not so much fun okay
mob round or mob round oh they're in the
fireplace why not oh yes it's only I say
late early you're racist oh well that's
a good way to start off this game ha ha
give me more one more
well that guy having a crown on his head
did I just kill a king for some stranger
II
ma'am he obviously be very careful
because do you hit a button too many
times you la mess up your combos going
on oh come on oh hell right on his
crotch haha oh sorry we meant to do this
kill you
another King another death oh so cool
it's so cool goes another Prince
I guess so Kingdom she's gonna crumble
oh well
trying to slice me know oh what a finish
Oh oh god I could play this all day [ __ ]
god damn is so cool oh it's so cool and
it makes you feel so good like you're
actually doing something but in reality
I brought terrible in this game see I'm
terrible they doesn't matter because
right now I've forgot the ball of death
oh what's that there okay bald it's out
of your Bam Bam Bam oh oh oh sorry
oh oh you wanted to dance that way I got
high
oh sorry meant to do that
bum bum bum by bang-bang oh sorry thank
you
I can't I can't even come up with
intelligible words to say just cuz it's
so cool oh I think that my commentary is
exactly the same when it was the last
time I played it
we're just mostly alanna me going oh and
just nothing else I'm only gonna play
one more round because I don't think my
heart could take it it's just too much
fun and now I want to play on my own but
that's okay because oh unlock survival
boner hmm have you real huh Wow okay so
anyway either way I'm just gonna play
this last one and that'll be it maybe
I'll try to unlock the mop round I'm
gonna I thought I needed to do something
else there I forget this game plays
itself ok the blue guys I just learned
go past you when they need to hit Oh bye
Frank nope nope nope nope nope nope
oh hey what are you doing uh but mine
Fleiss blizzardy slice Hey oh it's so
cool because they like place environment
there it's like you're on a stage and
you're just putting up a show for
everybody see whoa yes please thank you
goodbye sir thank you hi fun fun fun
the thing is actually not to panic
because if you're more patient oh sorry
you can actually do a lot better than
what you do if you were not patient
which is usually what I do and I just
scream and press a whole bunch of
Legends to hope for the best
okay so anyway gah god I love this game
I love it so much
ah I can do a whole series just me
playing this game but I won't because
that would not be good content they'll
just be ridiculous silliness but either
way this is one of my favorite games
just cuz it's so simple it's so fun it's
so fast-paced it's plain old awesome so
if you want to see the first time I
played it was about a year ago now I
pretty much did the same thing so check
it out for yourselves hope you enjoyed
this video for what it was
thank you all so much for watching check
out the other awesome games I played in
the annotation or the description below
and as always I will see you
ha
I don't know because I'm gonna edit this
and it's gonna be an amalgamation of the
people are gonna sing oh oh my gosh come
on